Donald Trump spokeswoman Healy
Baumgartner has quit because she just
can't handle the Donald Trump campaign
anymore who cares why does it matter
well it matters because Healy is one of
the most kooky and bizarre people who
has worked for Trump during this
campaign and even she is seeing through
the insanity of what is going on here
now as a reminder Healy Baumgartner went
into what I could only describe as a
talking point coma which went completely
viral after we covered it she's no
longer comfortable with the Trump
campaign and has resigned here is a
quote from Miz Baumgartner it is clear
the campaign is now going in a direction
I am no longer comfortable with and I
have decided to move on Baumgartner has
worked on four presidential campaigns
she says she still looks forward to
quote honorably casting my vote for mr.
Trump on election day many problems for
the Trump campaign right now he loses a
debate embarassingly and then his damage
control is even more embarrassing and
ridiculous than the debate performance
he goes on a middle-of-the-night Twitter
rant about a sex tape involving a woman
whose looks and weight he previously
criticized he's accused of doing illegal
business in Cuba which could hurt him
big time in Florida and then Kellyanne
Conway goes on the view and basically
admits that yes Donald Trump's business
did spend money in Cuba which would have
been illegal and then all of a sudden
it's too crazy for Healy Baumgartner
there is one thing that has sort of gone
Donald Trump's way in the last few days
and I know that some people are going to
laugh and they'll say David you're
digging pretty damn deep here to find
something positive to say about Trump
remember how Trump said that in that
first debate he had a faulty microphone
the debate Commission put out a
one-sentence statement saying there were
issues regarding Donald Trump's audio
that affected the sound level in the
debate Hall no mention of the sound
level for the television broadcast which
was seen by 83 million people that was
absolutely fine
I still don't even know what they mean
maybe what they mean is Trump's audio in
the room to the few hundred people in
the room was lower than Hillary
Clinton's I don't know but Trump
vindicated on maybe the most meaningless
thing he's talked about over the last
two weeks and on all of the big issues
things still really not looking good I I
will miss Healy Baumgartner we still
have Katrina Pierson that's something I
guess
but Healy Baumgartner involved in go
back and check out the clip on our
YouTube channel it was a it was a
conversation about who Trump is meeting
with why is Trump meeting with Henry
Kissinger can she confirm the meeting
can she not she was a spokeswoman but
she said she doesn't speak on behalf of
the Trump campaign well hold on a second
that's exactly what a spokeswoman does
you are speaking on behalf of someone
else one of the funniest clips from this
entire election cycle and we bid
farewell to Healy Baumgartner